[Music]
most opposition candidates asked people
to boycott Madagascar's presidential
election at some polling stations lines
were short president Andre rajin wants a
third term in office and says he's
confident people will turn out and he
will win in the first round of
voting for those who don't participate
we won't Force anyone to participate but
for the people is their right and their
responsibility to do their duty to vote
and that's why I want to thank the
people because even here people are
motivated even if they have been
encouraged not to vote 10 opposition
candidates called for a boycott saying
the Electoral commission and the courts
favored the incumbent but political
tensions didn't stop others from voting
election observers say voting day went
relatively
smoothly I think that Madagascar's
democracy is Advanced we'll just
encourage them to consolidate what has
been achieved and to correct what needs
to be corrected the Indian Ocean island
is the leading Global producer of
vanilla but the World Bank says
Madagascar is one of the world's poorest
countries whoever wins this election
will have to address widespread poverty
as well as manage any Fallout that could
happen if results are disputed har
mutasa Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer